when i was deciding whether to work here
i don't even know if you remember this
um i had worked with
um not in the media world but i'd worked
behind closed doors with
folks who they call me and say hey
deloney i'm
president of such and such i'm this and
this
i think i've done the thing that's going
to get me in trouble or get me fired and
i need some
talk through this with me one of the
most common things that became a
uh like just i just started beating this
drum years ago
it was you gotta have people
the the more successful you are the
lonelier you get
and so i don't know if you remember this
one of the questions i asked you in our
interview
was who do you listen to who do you hang
out with and you rattled off three or
four different groups and i
left and i remember calling sheila on
the way home my wife on the way home and
said
um dave and i are gonna disagree about
stuff and i don't even
fully know what this job is but i trust
him
and um but i trust him and because he's
got people speaking to him
it's been my experience that there's a
shift that happens
when you become successful so you get
your medical degree and you become a
doctor
and you have your same buddies from med
school and you have your wives friends
or your husband's friends and y'all hang
out
and then suddenly you buy the practice
and then you and two partners buy the
other practice
and then pretty soon your house gets a
little bit bigger and your car gets
nicer
and then people start going to your
house because
it's your house not because they're
going to hang out with you and they
start waiting for your
fill in the blank your party you have
the coolest halloween
stuff or whatever and then slowly they
those intimate little hey bring whatever
casserole you've got whatever half
bottle of wine you gotta come over to my
house
those start going away because they just
turned into shows productions
have you experienced in your arc the
tightening of that circle
or a loneliness or you seem to really
cultivate
people around you i've experienced it um
it has the opportunity to do that and
the reason it does that is not because
you um uh
seek isolation or something but uh
everyone goes through an evolution of
friends yeah
if you're only friends when you're 50
are your high school buddies that's a
problem your uncle rico on napoleon
dynamite okay i mean
you know so that's just you should have
outgrown
some of those people and here's this i
remember
or they should have outgrown you or we
should have had
value based you know disagreements that
don't allow us to have real close
intimate conversations anymore
and this is an important thing to to i
had buddies that you know they're doing
cocaine still and i'm 60.
so they're not my buddies right i mean
i'm not mad at them i'm not mean to them
i don't shame them
but i don't need them hanging out at my
house right
i remember a buddy of mine became a
college president and
suddenly we didn't i didn't go to the
fights anymore he didn't have us over
yeah and i remember thinking that's the
rightest smartest thing for this guy to
do because delony's a hothead
and especially 15 years ago i'm gonna
say something stupid about when i was
over so
so he there was a natural evolution on
behalf of the of this
well i wasn't that makes sense yeah but
i'm not guarding this place or guarding
our lives that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying that
the the the you're gonna have a few
people that make it all the way through
your life with you and then you're gonna
develop new friends as you grow
and change right that you have intimacy
with in in terms of an intimate
conversation i mean not sexual intimacy
but the uh but the uh uh you know and so
i'm sharon and i are going to dinner
tonight with a couple that we have hung
out with for 35 years
so they're on the inside of the inside
they knew dave ramsey before there was a
dave ramsey right they
they were there when i was going broke
you know and so uh and we're still good
friends but the guy reads like a maniac
um i mean he's not uber business
successful
but but very successful and uh so i
don't go to him for business insights
um because our scale is different but uh
so that's a guy from way back but then
i'm you know
i i'm i'm perfectly content with
uh henry cloud is a really good personal
friend and that's happened in the last
uh eight years yeah you know it's not
35-year relationships an eight-year
relationship but henry and i email
once a month once a week about something
trading some stupid joke or whatever and
um anytime i'm in la we're hanging out
or he's over here we're hanging out and
he does events with us and we hang out
with him and
um what's your trust metric when is it a
gradual thing or do you oh definitely
okay definitely and i'm looking uh i'm
looking for authenticity i struggle with
that
authenticity i struggle because i can
smell i can smell a fake
yeah my way i'm not real discerning on
some things
it's easy to lie to me i've been lied to
a lot
um and people get away with it they want
to impress you right well or period just
not not just me but i'm just in general
my
my ability to detect that's horrible
but uh my ability to detect a fake i can
just
i can walk in the room and just go yeah
because i was one
uh huh you're just you know you're just
you're just acting like you know
just if we could buy you for what you're
worth and sell you for what you think
you're worth son you'd be something you
know we make some money on you
but no they're not he's not a real dude
or she's not a real dude i can smell
those putting on the dog and the plastic
stuff and oh
god man just be real just go
you know i'm just some days suck some
days don't
we're just you know let's have some
meatloaf a little ketchup on it and
white beans and cornbread and you know
um
and we'll just sit down here and and
talk together and hang out we may laugh
about stupid stuff we may
tell 13 year old boy jokes we may
whatever but let's just
you know if for god's sakes be real yeah
how do you
i just i feel like in my life the
temptation is to always go home and just
shut the door
do you get energy from being alone or
you get energy from other people oh i'm
an extrovert i get energy okay other
people
sharon gets energy from being alone so
it keeps us balanced so
so i don't over do that and i don't like
the uh
social uh setting the uh
the classic party where you stand around
you know the drink in your hand what do
you do and i don't give a crap
you know all that stuff that drives me
bananas but but to sit down and hang
yeah with people that i love and the
thing i
back to your other question a minute ago
i want to add to it right quick um
because i think it's a principle other
people can use and i would suggest it
um as you grow don't be afraid to
ask people that are slightly or even
much more successful than you at a given
thing
into your life if you can if they're
authentic if they're real
right uh because you'd be amazed at
that all these successful people are are
uh
really all success is is a pile of all
the mistakes you've made and you're
standing on it rather than laying under
it
gotcha so they have all climbed a
mountain of garbage to
understand you know that they have all
shoveled you know the more
new levels new devils right that you
know they have shoveled manure at levels
that you hadn't shoveled it maybe
and they have hurt at levels you haven't
hurt they've been betrayed and lied
about it maybe at levels you haven't yet
and uh don't be afraid to hang out with
them if they'll be real
yeah now you know i know people in show
business or
radio or leadership training or whatever
that aren't they're fakie
but but though i'm amazed at somebody
like at a henry cloud level uh who sold
10 million books you know
uh that a guy like that or i can name
other names i'll start dropping names
i'm not gonna do that but
but these guys that are uber successful
they
need and want friendship too yes
that's my thing and so if you just ask
like the first time i did that was
20 years ago i formed an eagles group we
called it
and um i made a list of men
that i knew well and men that i just
knew
who they were and i knew they had a good
marriage
i knew they were walking with god at
some level
and i i knew that they had some level of
success
in their field they were music people
they were pastors of
good size organizations uh they were um
authors uh they were business people of
some kind
and i emailed 12 guys and some of them
were like studs
i mean eagles you know and i was like
wow if i could just
the fact that i could get their email
was kind of like intimidating
man and i asked 12 of them to get
together once a week and
study the bible or read a book and just
talk and be guys together and just
create a group of guys for just to love
each other and encourage each other and
be accountable to over time
as we built relationship just a short
email like that
you know how many of them came the first
meeting all of them
wow and these are household names these
are if i started naming them off
people today you know people would know
who i was talking about
about 9 out of 12 or household names
and one of the guys i'm having dinner
with tonight you know the same
so he's still that group that group
lasted 12 years
but but what my point is is that don't
be afraid to ha
invite people into your life that are
new
that are that that have that have the
stuff
because they need it too and i i
know they need it they most of my time
my experience been they desperately want
it yeah they heard for it yeah
and many of us go back to middle school
i don't care how successful we are
i didn't get invited to that so i'm just
gonna i'm gonna head home and
and i'm just gonna that's i'm good i'm
cool and and the car's getting nice
and the the dinners get nicer but you're
still by yourself right yeah and man i
would love to be included into a thing
we all want to be including a thing
but again it goes back dave
i i talk to a single mom i talk to a dad
who just wants to be a better husband i
talk to
fill in the blank fill in the blank
filling blank and they the expectation
is these things
just happen and what you just described
was a
highly intentional i need this
i i am valued enough that i need other
people
and i'm gonna do the work and get these
guys email addresses i'm gonna set it up
i'm gonna go
first goes back to that well and i knew
that as we grew
that i would go back to your earlier
question that i would go into isolation
because i'd be too cool for school
potentially and that that's where people
crash that's that's it
that's when leaders die this is where
leaders go to die isolation
and arrogance and secret lives off to
the side
and think that nobody sees this stuff
well god sees it
and um and you know you're not getting
away from it yeah and so i knew uh i
have the benefit of a wife who is not
impressed at all with dave ramsey
i have that same i have the same
blessing and so that's a good starting
point for accountability and then i had
that group of guys and
when that group broke up i formed
another group with a little different
mindset
and a little different thing but still
with the same idea of
deep relationships with men who will
call you out right
and so when you know when ramsay's
getting hammered in the press
you know who's emailed me those 11 guys
okay
six of them will carry my casket yeah
and and
that man what that's a great one to
leave on here but
going all the way back to
every single person i've ever met has
crashed
maybe not as spectacularly as as you did
everybody crashes everybody messes up
everybody well
moral crash is more what i was concerned
about or integrity crashes no i'm saying
all arrogance
back to your your bankruptcy right yeah
yeah we all are growing and
i don't care how small you think your
situation is or how
quote-unquote big it is you're in a big
building with your name on it
it goes back to that intentionality i'm
going to surround myself with people who
know stuff i don't know
because i want to learn i'm going to
surround myself people who are gonna
teach me to be a better husband better
dad better business leader better
whatever
i'm gonna surround myself with i'm gonna
go first and practice
friends and that sounds so dumb right
because when you're a kid they just
shove
my kids will play with any rando our
kids hung out with rachel's kids the
other day
took eight minutes and then they're off
telling stories and i don't know what
they're doing
right yeah it's weirder with us right
with grown-ups we have too many shells
and layers and we're not
it's going first and saying i deserve to
have friends well they're so
desperate to be impressive that you're
not that you impress nobody because
you're alone right
well you're not impressive because
you're fake yes so you're just
you're putting up all this stuff instead
of just going hey
there's some good air and there's some
bad get ready man i'm bringing the
casserole out yeah
exactly right yeah it's beautiful well
brother thanks for your time it's
super valuable honored to have you and
listen i'm so proud of what you're doing
here thanks man
absolutely amazing i listen to podcasts
on my runs on my walks in the morning
and uh you're taking some weird calls
and you're taking some good calls
and you're helping a lot of people and
i'm so
proud of the doctor john delaney show
and dr john dolone and the
healthcare people and i'm proud it's
part of our team here well i'm grateful
for you man
and for the the listeners i there was a
moment when i said
um that exact thing dave i don't i don't
know what this job is
and you're asking me to i'm gonna leave
something that i've worked for
15 20 years to do i've never done this
and
you said trust me no i trust i knew you
could do this and man i'm so
grateful that i did i knew this was
going to be big ah and it's just begun
man it's it's going to be my silly
little thing we're doing here it's wild
man
get ready baby hold on well i'm grateful
for you appreciate you
baby hold on i know my father-in-law
rode bulls man
he's been telling me that for years all
right appreciate you man have a good